peaches right the big Demeter
Aegis is reacting what are the holidays
like for peaches what everyone drops
kill to be Dennis quit your dream why my
God how great is that way are you so
much of the show is about holiday
tradition yeah do you guys have specific
holiday traditions you always do myself
yeah yeah I go out and stress shop hmm
that's always what do you buy what do
you need to get there they're out you
know of all the stuff that you really
want and I'm one of those people it's
still I get so frustrated on you know
buy stuff online that I have to go to
for some recent stuff to go to a
physical store good
are you a compulsive buyer I'm not to be
there all that stuff at the checkout you
know
yeah the snacks impulse right wench gum
always your last purchase rocket yeah I
mean I of course for the for the dog by
the cornice right what about you what
are the holiday traditions Christmas Eve
at Grandma's house and Christmas Day
with the family cut down to a different
group and a lot of booze snow aunts and
uncles driving when they shouldn't but
you know we're a very funny family but
it this family is very sweet in a lot of
ways but definitely with the traditions
you know you've fallen with the same
things growing up so when you come back
you turn back in a little kid it's like
running into a high school teacher when
you're a grown
which has happened to me recently and I
feel like I'm 14 with a desk in the
hallway again you know what was that
what was that I spent a lot of time on
the desk in the hall it was called a
creative destruction if we gotta get to
that I haven't seen you do many sitcoms
before we start this yeah yeah it was
zero I've done before
what was the immigrating next generation
sitcoms yeah we gotta find them the
greatest people and it was actually the
very best people you possibly do one
with because I've never done one before
and I was the weakest member of the cast
really for the first couple of weeks oh
yes I was because I it's a very
different animal do you like aspirin for
advice like comedies just about swing
the second you see what I do and then
you take it back just
[Laughter]